2020 has been a year of bad news and
things aren't much different in the
world of television
sadly a number of much-loved tv series
have come to an end this year here's the
real reason these tv shows were canceled
in 2020.
the reality police show cops began all
the way back in march 1989
and continued airing new episodes for 30
years
this is despite the show being cancelled
by its original network home box in may
2013
before getting a second lease on life at
spike tv which later became the
paramount network
after spike picked up the series studio
president kevin k told the hollywood
reporter
cops is a remarkable series that has
been able to sustain strong ratings well
into its third decade
a monumental achievement in television
but this remarkable series wouldn't last
forever
and in june 2020 the paramount network
made the announcement that cops had
finally reached the end of the line
the show's abrupt ending came in the
wake of worldwide protests against
race-based police brutality
a matter that many critics have long
accused cops of minimizing
according to the new york times in 2013
civil rights group color of change
proclaimed the show's producers have
built a profit model around distorted
and dehumanizing portrayals of black
americans and the criminal justice
system
in the wake of 2020's protest over
police brutality these complaints found
a renewed sense of impact
and likely influence the show's
cancellation this wasn't the only reason
cops ended though
for example cop's future wasn't helped
by the fact that according to deadline
paramount network has been moving away
from all unscripted programming
in october 2020 vulture reported that
cops was briefly resuming production but
only quote to fulfill commitments to
overseas territories
these episodes won't air in the u.s
arrow was to the arrowverse what iron
man was to the marvel cinematic universe
a barrage of superhero shows spun off
from this green arrow tv show which
kicked off its run on october 2012
but everything ends eventually and so it
was with arrow which aired its final
episode on january 28 2020
the news of arrow's final season was
announced via a tweet by the show's lead
actor stephen amell who tweeted
playing oliver queen has been the
greatest professional experience of my
life but you can't be a vigilante
forever arrow will return for a final
run of 10 episodes
this fall there's so much to say for now
i just want to say thank you
amel later expanded on his thoughts on
leaving the show revealing that he was
the primary impetus for the show's end
and that he had originally hoped arrow
could go on without him the iconography
of green arrow has always
been something that's bigger than
than me or any other actor that's
playing him or voicing him
like iron man arrow is now gone from the
universe he began but the show's legacy
will doubtless live on
when it debuted on abc in february 2015
the sitcom fresh off the boat was the
first network primetime show to feature
an asian american family in 20 years
as eddie wong whose memoir of the series
was based on said to over 1 000 guests
that fresh off the boat's premiere party
today
we've arrived starring randall park and
constance wu
the landmark program would go on to run
for six seasons
after exceeding 100 episodes abc
announced that fresh off the boat would
be pulling into port for good
once its sixth season wrapped up in
february 2020.
in a statement regarding the show's
cancellation abc president kerry burke
said
we couldn't be prouder of this
game-changing show and the impact it has
had on our cultural landscape
burke didn't give a specific reason for
the show's cancellation however variety
later noted
the series had seen its ratings decline
as it went on and was moved to friday
nights for its fifth season
diminishing ratings would easily explain
the show's cancellation
as would the increasingly busy schedules
of its lead actors
nevertheless a powerful legacy of fresh
off the boat is certain to keep on
resonating for years to come
in june 2019 the good place creator
michael sher dropped a bombshell about
his beloved nbc comedy the show would be
wrapping up after its fourth season
where many of the cancellations in 2020
happened at the whims of network
executives the good place ended exactly
when its creator wanted it to
sure explained after the good place was
picked up for season 2 the writing staff
and i began to map
out as best we could the trajectory of
the show given the ideas we wanted to
explore and the pace at which we wanted
to present those ideas i began to feel
like four seasons
just over 50 episodes was the right
lifespan this aligned with prior
comments sure made about the temporary
nature of the good place
in particular sure mentioned to the
hollywood reporter in december 2018
this is not a show that's destined to be
on for nine years it's not a 200 episode
friends kind of deal
it's not a hangout show it's
understandable if good place fans wanted
the show to go on forever
after all nobody wants to see their
favorite show come to an end but those
fans can at least rest assured that sure
and his team were satisfied with the
final series and that the good place got
to end on its own forking terms
take it sleazy the original penny
dreadful which also ended before its
time in 2016
received widespread critical acclaim the
first season's rotten tomatoes consensus
declared that skillfully shot and
superbly acted penny dreadful is
perplexing in a good way
even if it's a bit silly at times more
than that the original series also
established its own dedicated fan pace
so given how widely liked the program
was it was inevitable that a spin-off
would continue the penny dreadful saga
enter penny dreadful city of angels
which took the franchise across the pond
to los
angeles gave it a fresh 1930 setting and
featured a brand new cast
while the show's creator john logan
publicly teased details for a second
season of city of angels the spin-off
sadly wasn't made to last
in a statement the show's network
showtime said showtime has decided not
to move forward with another season of
penny dreadful city of angels
we would like to thank executive
producers john logan michael aguilar and
the entire casting crew for their
outstanding work on this project
no reason was given for the cancellation
but speculation has attributed it to low
viewership
according to screen rant the series
premiere only brought in around 800 000
viewers
and things only went downhill from there
by the finale only around 650 000 people
were watching
with numbers like that it's probably no
surprise that city of angels was sent
straight to tv
hell in may 2019 deadline wrote
netflix might be rewriting the rule book
with a business model than of all shows
off and running for two to three seasons
sadly this practice has led to
criminally short runs for shows like
daredevil and altered carbon
one exception to this rule however is
the ashton kutcher sitcom the ranch
the half hour comedy kicked off its run
in april 2016
and proceeded to go on for eight seasons
and eighty episodes before finally
wrapping up in january 2020
reporting on the show's cancellation
deadlines suggested that the show had
never been expected to go beyond four
seasons
the idea that the ranch would go on in
its own terms was reflected in comments
by its leading man who told wtf with
marc maron the story of the ranch was
told i love everything that we did
netflix owns the show so it's not like
there was this big syndication boom that
was going to come if we shot two more
seasons
and although the ranch has been put out
to pasture it can at least hold its head
high
since it managed to surpass fuller house
and claim the title of netflix's
longest-running multi-camera comedy
in 2019 variety announced the empire has
fallen
fox announced monday that music drama
empire's recently announced sixth season
will be the show's last the news came as
a shock for empire creator lee daniels
however who didn't expect the show to
end so soon
he told the rap i was surprised honestly
i was told that it was possible this
could happen but it has become realer
and realer the closer we get to the end
and i am sad
sad that our show is done so just why
did empire crumble after six seasons
fox gave no official word on the matter
but the hollywood reporter noted that
the show's shift to being a disney owned
show likely played a part in the matter
the outlet also noted that jesse
smallett's ongoing legal affairs
probably had an
impact on the show's premature end it
also can't be forgotten that empire
suffered a sharp drop in ratings over
the years
going from 9.9 million viewers for its
season premiere to just 2.9 million
viewers for the series finale
the reasons for empire's abrupt ending
were many though the drama surrounding
the show didn't end with its
cancellation unfortunately the 20
episode final season was cut down by two
episodes due to the covet 19 pandemic
this didn't just result in a shorter
season it meant that empire's intended
series finale was never filmed wrapping
the show's run on a very sour noted
for a long time it appeared that
supernatural would never end
having kicked off in september 2005 the
fantastical exploits of sam and dean
winchester managed to go on for 15
seasons at a whopping 320 episodes
and sure the dynamic duo managed to
conquer a variety of otherworldly beans
in that time span
but even they couldn't defeat the
prospect of cancellation the news that
supernatural's 15th season would be its
last was announced via jared padilecki's
instagram account
he wrote dear espn family season 1
jensen ackles and i want you to know
that next season season 15 will be the
last season of supernatural
fellow lead actor jensen ackel said the
decision to end the show was an
intentional one
explaining it was months and months if
not years of discussion between he and i
between the rest of the cast between
crew between our writers between our
producers between the studio between the
network
nobody wanted to see this show fizzle
out true to form supernatural's final
season has managed to go on much longer
than expected
the series was originally set to
conclude in may 2020 but the covet 19
pandemic shut down filming for the final
season
the production was only able to resume
in august meaning that the supernatural
series finale won't air until november
19
2020 five months later than originally
intended
netflix's first original animated
cartoon aimed at adults kicked off its
run in august 2014.
initial reviews were mixed but it wasn't
long before bojack horseman had become
one of the most critically acclaimed
shows around
oh no the responsibilities are already
starting
in particular bojack was lauded for its
inimitable mix of light-hearted humor
and heart-wrenching forays into
addiction depression and the dark side
of hollywood the show's rotten tomato
consensus for season six
reads bittersweet and brilliant to the
very end bojack horseman's final season
manages to keep surprising viewers with
his empathy in depth
solidifying its place is one of tv's
greatest offerings
and at long last bojack horseman came to
an end in january 2020.
the conclusion was not one imposed by
the show's creator raphael bob waxburg
but rather came from netflix which gave
bob waxburg advanced warning that the
end was near as he told andy wire
they don't have to do that obviously but
i said i would appreciate it if i could
have the forewarning to give the show a
proper finale and not set up some
cliffhangers that will never pay off
so when they picked up season 6 they
said hey remember how you asked for that
heads up
we think that this is your heads up
while bojack horseman may have come to
an end it at least went out on a genuine
high and cemented itself as one of the
funniest and most emotional shows of the
last decade
really in the end isn't that all you can
ask for
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one